No, no. South Africa has responsibilities.
We can't escape our responsibilities.
And we must, uh,
care for the security of South West Africa
until there is a lasting peace
so that the people of South West Africa can,
through deliberation amongst themselves,
decide on their own future in a peaceful way.
Until we've reached that stage,
South Africa will have to continue its, uh,
Protection of Southwest Africa
and see to it that South Africa is carried to its full,
uh, independence on a peaceful way.
Why is the security of South West Africa
so important to South Africa?
We don't want chaos on our borders.
We don't want chaos in the rest of southern Africa.
As a matter of fact,
we are striving for peaceful solutions
and stability in the whole of southern Africa.